i don't know man i think we're we're
getting to the point where they're
losing the ability to control the
systems the way we we think they would
new hampshire for instance the free
state project i mean these guys are
getting more people on board with
seceding from the union now will that
happen
i think it's highly unlikely but what
happens when you have the free state
project saying everybody come to new
hampshire sign a pledge saying we out
what happens when 80 of new hampshire is
like yo we out
and then what happens if there's like
mass non-compliance with the federal
government's laws
the feds don't have enough people to go
in and deal with like i think new
hampshire only has like eight hundred
thousand people in it not many yeah yeah
do you want to check the
population but i mean how is the how is
the federal government going to deal
with 800
block the highways or something like
what do you do and it's not just new
hampshire it's other i mean texas
texas has constantly pushed those
buttons i don't know i mean what do you
think do you think texas would ever get
to that point
yeah i do actually i think it'll be
sooner than a lot of people think um and
and you're right it's to me what they
like just hypothetically speaking yeah
if if two-thirds of texans voted in a
referendum that we want to break away it
would be difficult as the u.s lectures
the world about self-determination you
know what if they just started reading
them the declaration of independence to
them and so what what part of this do
you not agree with anymore you know and
and
it would be important too
to not have any you know no violence
suggested just to say no we're breaking
away so that if washington starts
ordering the air force to bomb them it's
going to be pretty clear-cut what
happened right right so this is the
thing you know people often say oh the
government the feds would never allow
secession because they would go send the
military in and i'm like that would make
people more uh
like supportive of secession
right they would see the aggressor being
the federal government going in and
rounding people up they'd see crying
babies and screaming women and be like
this is crazy like they didn't even do
anything and uh i think more and more
people would actually actually it's it's
not just similar from the american civil
war with fort sumter when the fighting
broke out i think it was seven other
states that were like whoa that's crazy
we're out and then word traveled way
slower in the era of fourth and fifth
generational warfare you got to have
propaganda on your side which means
often
you know you want to be the victim right
you want to be the one getting hit going
oh they're attacking me help me and then
people sympathize with you
so that's why i'm i'm wondering like
what would happen if new hampshire said
we hereby secede it's done and the
federal government says no you don't
they say don't care not listening are
they gonna send in the feds are
collecting taxes or what right so i i've
done been doing research on like
non-violent resistance you know think
like like the civil rights struggle just
to give an example of people they had
training back in the 60s where like when
they would do a sit-in and they would
train the people and say okay the mobs
are going to come and start punching and
screaming and spitting at you
don't swear at them and just sit there
and take it and then when you've taken
too much we rotate so the guys on the
inside
are the circumference now and they take
it you know what i mean and that was so
it wasn't just oh let's love everyone no
it was strategic because they knew we're
outnumbered you know we have to win
public opinion and then enough people
watching tv are like you know seeing
firemen you know hose down marchers you
know yeah i don't know if i'm afraid
that so you're right with new hampshire
again so
and that's why right now again they're
making this propaganda effort to talk
about how the right-wing threat and all
these you know what i mean because they
want the public to believe when they're
kicking in doors
it's because there's all these
right-wing kooks who pose a threat not
just people who say you know what i want
to break away and not not be affiliated
with washington dc anymore got a number
here it's 1.36 million people in uh
that's a 2019 1.36 million in uh new
hampshire more than i thought yeah you
know i think
saying we want to break away is like
saying i'm anti that i hate that i'm
voting against that rather than being
against it you want to say we're create
we're fixing this american system and
then
all these people around the country will
start doing it together and that is not
going to be considered if you say i'm
breaking away they're going to say
that's anti-american and other people
would be brainwashed fifth generation
but if you say we're fixing this
together that's gonna that's gonna tweak
their minds and make them join you when
you you know you make a good point all
of this rhetoric about the far right and
everything is getting people ready for
when start kicking the doors down right
they're gonna be like oh you know but uh
new hampshire
that's going to be a cold splash of
water in the face to a lot of people who
are like wait an entire state is trying
to secede
wait a minute and i'll tell you this
they're not hearing this when they turn
on cnn so right now i assure you most
people like i'd be willing to bet
and uh i i would say this
if i was looking at
two options of voting you know
does the the leftist youtuber severe
bread tube know about new hampshire
session or don't they i bet they don't i
would say i will put my chip on they
don't know about this
and they're not paying attention to it
and it doesn't matter to them even
though they're supposedly libertarian
now i i think it's fair to say many of
them probably do but i think it's not
part of the conversations they're having
in which case
even to those people who are supposedly
like more you know uh politically
oriented
and regular people none of them are
probably seeing the stories in the news
about how i think it's like up to five
reps i think so five or so four five was
last
in new hampshire who are like we favor
secession that's a tiny amount relative
to the hundreds or so that they have
it's growing but that's a that's a
conversation you think
like
if you you would think that the state of
jefferson that several counties in
oregon voted to see from the state to
join idaho and then northern california
that there's a county in northern
colorado that wants to join wyoming yeah
well
right and that you know even
california's talked about secession
texas has talked about secession new
hampshire has found the paperwork texas
paperwork before and there was a poll i
think it was yougov data we mentioned
often 37.2 percent of americans favor
their region breaking off from the u.s
to form a new regional government i'd be
willing to bet most people don't know
about that and even political leftists
don't know about that if one of these
states did
make an actual formal declaration it
would be like them waking up one day
with like the moon being upside down or
something weird like how do how are we
at this point if the government came and
said it's far right extremists they'd be
like all one million 1.3 million
it passed by 60 so you're saying like
700 000 people 800 000 people are all
far-right extremists or is that a whole
state saying yo we out right into ian's
point i think you're right so
with my you know when i talk about this
like i so we're using the term secession
just because it's very precise and we
all know you know your audience is very
informed but i would call it like the
texas independence movement you know
it's the same thing just like
technically the fourth of july they
seceded from great britain but we
consider it independence day i just
thought a good way to do it would be if
you set up a smart contract so that your
government secedes until your demands
are met the demands could be whatever
you want so like repeal the federal
reserve if the us government does that
we'll come back into the country and
then you could have a bunch of different
communities succeed at once with smart
contracts set up ready to reunify
you wouldn't need smart contracts the
problem is confidence
if people uh you you you guys have seen
for vendetta i assume yeah you know that
scene at the end where you know the the
um
what's the name of the inspector i'm not
gonna ask home or whatever i don't
remember he's like eventually someone
will do something stupid and then it
shows the uh the the finger man they
call them and he shoots a little girl
and then also everyone starts walking up
to him they have pipes and he's like ah
holding his badge but they don't care
because that is the point where people
no longer have confidence in the system
in the beginning of the movie when
natalie portman's character says oh god
you're fingerman that's her saying she
believes in the power of the state and
she fears it the end of the movie is
when people say we don't believe in your
power or care about it
so
in terms of you know breaking away
seceding peaceful divorce whatever if
people just don't believe in the power
of an institution
it doesn't exist the the reason i bring
up smart contracts with like your states
to say new hampshire secedes they have a
smart contract ready to bring them back
into the union when their demands are
made is because if some power hungry
monarch came into power in new hampshire
during that process and decided yeah
you'd repeal the federal reserve but i'm
not coming back now you'd have some
strong man so you want to automate it
trustless basically you can't automate
the process by which the public would
come to trust the government again yeah
it shouldn't be about trust well it
doesn't matter listen the point is if
you have you know uh let's say you got
1.3 million people in new hampshire and
they do a referendum on secession and 60
percent say okay we're going to vote so
you're looking at you know i guess what
would that be around six hundred oh six
sixty percent so maybe six six hundred
seven hundred thousand people seven
hundred or so thousand
those people have stated with that vote
we have no confidence in in the system
you can't then just have a system that
automatically turns around one day and
says oh all of you guys who voted
against this you are now back in the
system they say no we're not we don't
believe it for me it's not that i hate
the united states and that system but
there are aspects of it i want changed
so as like uh as like uh i don't know
what you would say like i'm i'm
boycotting this stupid government until
you fix these things i don't want to be
gone from the u.s forever but i'd be
happy to like you know put pressure them
to fix the system so when you're dealing
with several hundred thousand
individuals
you can't just one day snap your fingers
and if all of them agree
if seven hundred thousand people agree
we want out no matter what happens
there's no point at which you can just
turn around and say okay now you all
hereby agree to like the state and
believe in its power they'll be like no
we still don't believe in its power i
think i guess part of why i'm pushing
this is because i think if they if they
want it out if you really want to get
out of the united states that's not
going to happen the u.s federal
government would demolish any kind of
resistance like that they would send in
the federal they'd block off i-95 and
then they would bro i think you need to
understand what they have satellites
dude what
yeah i get it but jet planes like what
are you the free
the people who are going up to new
hampshire are not mom and pop like
soccer mom
you know local uh
managers these are people who want to
live in the middle of nowhere and hunt
for their food these are these are free
staters who are staunch libertarians and
caps who are going up there being like
good take it all away get away from me
i'm going to grow my own food and get
water from the ground so if the feds
came in and said we're cutting off the
the you know supply of tvs they'd be
like we don't care
they they'd find other stuff imports if
they yeah so so i i'm enjoying this
discussion so to your point that's why
my in my
writing about this stuff i focused on
texas first because they've got the two
oceans and they've got the border with
mexico it would be harder and you know
it's huge too it would be harder to seal
them up whereas
florida also there's many respects in
which you might think yeah they should
go to you know descent you know
president desantis or whatever but
it would be easier to just do a naval
blockade so i agree with you it would be
tricky but again if if they did it
peacefully and the only their only crime
was to say we're breaking away we're not
sending money to washington anymore and
they send in tanks and starve them into
submission
that might be a pr disaster you know and
there would be so much guerilla media
like showing oh you know what i mean
like right now like american troops
doing atrocities overseas if they were
doing it in new hampshire
that might not play with a lot of people
i mean that you you'd probably get
sanctions on the us all of a sudden
massive g7 trade partners would be like
we will not be trading with you until
you stop doing what you're doing
now
you you're right they could get away
with it if they found all these
right-wing you know depots of munitions
and you know what i mean like if they
were false the government could could
plausibly claim either because of the
false flag or because there really were
people who decided you know i'm sick of
this they've got msnbc it would be a
total pr nightmare for the new hampshire
people it would be terrible so it would
be good it would be you know
uh and they control the narrative and
then new hampshire the people would have
to appeal to another country to help
them because and then it would be like
who are they gonna appeal to canada i
don't think so china probably
you know the funniest thing about a new
hampshire session is it would basically
sever maine from the contiguous united
states yeah it can't happen they
wouldn't let that happen right right of
course
but i'm curious as to what their tactic
would be probably i'd imagine
at this point it would be to flood the
zone with money and resources to drown
out any conversation about a free state
but i got to tell you a grassroots
movement is something powerful
if more and more people keep flooding up
to new hampshire for the free state
project no amount of money is going to
shut that down right and at the very
least that's why i think it's worthwhile
like you know shows like there's people
talking about it just to because i'm
curious to hear like the people who you
know work for vox or the new york times
just get them on record to say
hypothetically if two-thirds of texans
voted to break away would you let them
go or would you think they should send
an airstrikes and tank you know i mean
just to have them on record because how
could they say or maybe they would say
yeah we wouldn't let them do that we're
talking about we're at a point
i'd be willing to bet
if we went to uh and polled democrats
should republican states be allowed to
secede they'd say yes
i think you will see a large portion say
yes let them go
now a year ago or there was a year or so
ago there was data from the new york
times on this and i think it was
something like 30 percent said
uh yes they can go
like 60 some odd percent said
overwhelmingly no they can't leave the
union
i think that's changed you know a year
on now especially as things are going
i'll tell you this come 2022
if republicans end up taking large
portions of the house and they end up
getting control back then you're going
to see the sentiment sentiment flip and
leftists are going to be like get them
out right we already we already saw the
podesta thing from the boston globe that
john podesta said the west coast should
secede from the union if donald trump
wins what happens when trump wins again
joe rogan
in the news simply for stating his
opinion i love how this always happens
joe's says he thinks trump's going to
run trump's going to win
if that happens the left is going to be
like how about we let you secede instead
of letting trump be president and then
what
how does that happen right and that's
that's um some of the arguments i've
been making too is to say to like let's
call them blue state voters just for
lack of a better term
suppose it were texas and they wanted to
break away
let them go because all the people in
your state you know if you're in
california or some other blue state new
york whatever
a lot of people would move to texas then
so you get rid of them you know those
gun nuts or the people who don't want to
get vaccinated get it get them away from
you and go if texas did leave the union
democrats would never lose a
presidential election right for the
remaining you know u.s system so it's
kind of a win-win and that's not like a
paradox like you know
armies agree to not use poison gas
against each other you know i mean there
are
things that and this would avoid a lot
of conflict so i to me it's i'm not just
trying to like trick the left or
something i'm saying no it's can't we
all agree
if texas wants to leave let them go
that's better for everybody but look we
end up seeing sarah silverman comes out
on her show saying maybe we need a
peaceful would you say separation i
don't know if she said
did she say peaceful divorce so that
means she must be listening to michael
malus because i'm more into the peaceful
separation which is why i bring up the
smart contract civil disobedience angle
because you can leave and then come back
when you divorce it's gone forever no
ian you you're not understanding like
we're talking about
if
like why do you believe us dollars are
valuable right because you can go to the
store and buy stuff yeah what if one day
the clerk said i don't want your money
it's not worth anything to me it's
useless though would there be one day
where you convinced him no the smart
contract changed therefore you have to
take it now he'd be like get out of my
store what do you mean what do you mean
by that let's say
you have
800 000 people all say one day we no
longer want to accept us dollars we
think it's valueless
and then you're like but we'll do a
smart contract that says as soon as the
fed's gone we'll all take this back and
then one day the system comes back and
if the smart contract flips and now
everyone is mandated to accept dollars
again and you walk into the gas station
do you think that clerk will just change
his mind or do you think he's going to
be like i said i don't take that money
anymore get out
the smart contract will not change
public confidence in a system if the
system if the confidence breaks there's
no reversing it
i mean maybe over a few decades and a
few generations you can rebuild that
network but it doesn't work i see what
you mean that people are going to do
what they're used to doing regardless of
what the law says but if you could
digitally because
things are going digital now if you
could just digitally kind of just change
the money like so you're using us
dollars now tomorrow you're using texas
dollars and then when they finally
repeal the federal reserve you're using
us dollars again
i mean i think that sounds like a pipe
dream i think seceding peacefully is a
pipe dream because there's no way the
most powerful military that's ever been
ever existed would let a piece of their
economy just walk away i agree like in
oregon these counties want to succeed
like as if portland's going to let their
serfs go
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you